tengo aquí el número complejo coseno de
dos tercios de p2p entre tres más y
veces el seno de dos mil entre tres y
quiero elevar ese número a la veinteava
potencia así que bien los invito a
pausar el vídeo y tratar de resolver
este problema como siempre por ustedes
mismos asumiendo que ya lo hicieron
vamos a pensar lo primero que voy a
hacer es trabajar con este número
complejo que está aquí en azul y
claramente está escrito en la forma
polar y es un número complejo que tiene
norma 1 módulo 1 y argumento de 2 pi
entre 3 tiene argumento de 2 p / 3
incluso si quisieran lo podrían escribir
en la forma polar pura como el módulo la
norma desde el número complejo 1 por el
coseno
de 2000 entre 32 y entre 3 más y veces
el seno
2 / 3 son exactamente el mismo número
complejo y bueno dónde está este número
pues veamos si lo pongo aquí si lo
gráfico el argumento es 206 y cada uno
de estos rayos son 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 así que cada uno de estos rayos es
y entre 12 y como yo sé que 2 pi entre 3
es lo mismo que mucho y multiplicó el
numerador y el denominador por 4 obtengo
8 y entre 12 entonces solo tengo que
moverme 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
tengo que llegar ahí ese es mi número
complejo ok entonces ya que pensé en eso
vamos a tratar de elevarlo vamos a
tratar de elevarlo a la veinteava
potencia y para hacer eso me voy a basar
en la fórmula de hoy les les recuerdo la
fórmula de hoy leer me dice que es a la
ip está donde está es un número real
siempre va a ser igual a coseno de teta
coste no beteta más y veces el seno de
eta y como nos ayuda a esto pues si
escribo este número en la forma ella la
y teta
este número complejo es lo mismo que el
ala y por dos tercios
así que puede tomar este número y lo que
quiero hacer es elevarlo a la veinteava
potencia y ahora puede usar las
propiedades de los exponentes ya sé que
si tomo un número a un exponente y lo
quiero elevar a otro exponente los
exponentes se multiplican así que este
número es lo mismo que el ala y
por 20
por 2 entre 32 y entre 3 y cuánto es
esto pues eso es lo mismo que
a la iss por 40
40 p entre 3 ahora 40 pie entre 3 es un
número muy grande estoy dando demasiadas
vueltas para regresar al origen perdón
para regresar al punto que partí
entonces lo que quiero hacer es tratar
de convertir este argumento en un
argumento más pequeño empezamos pensando
cuánto es 40 pies 40 puntos 3 pues es lo
mismo que 40 entre 3 es 13 con un tercio
así que este número es 13 con un tercio
por pi pero cada vez que recorro dos pi
si salgo de aquí y recorro 2 pierce
regresó al mismo punto así que puedo
quitarle a este número una serie de
factores de dos para uno por cada vuelta
que le estoy dando esto así que vamos a
tratar de quitarle a 13
a 13 con un tercio por pin vamos a
quitarle algún múltiplo el múltiplo de
dos primas grandes que se le pueda
sustraer esto antes de que se vuelva
negativo así que le voy a quitar 12 p 12
y cuánto me queda pues 13 con un tercio
menos 12 y va a ser lo mismo que cuatro
tercios
así que este número es lo mismo que el
por y a la cuatro tercios
pero cuatro tercios cuatro tercios de pi
es lo mismo que cuánto cuatro terceros
es lo mismo que 16 y entre 12 así que
aquí estoy en 12 pi entre 12 13 14 15 16
llegaría aquí
justo a 15 13 14 15 16 aquí
así que este es el número que es igual a
coseno de 200 es más y veces el seno de
200 es elevado a la potencia 20 ahora
como tiene sentido esto conceptualmente
pues si este número que es igual a este
número está aquí qué pasaría si quisiera
elevar ahora este número de aquí el
número en azul a la potencia digamos 21
pues lo que haría sería sumar otros dos
tercios al argumento sea otros 8 y entre
12 así que vamos a ver 12345678 llegaría
justo ay ese sería el número que sería
igual a este número elevado a la
potencia 21 así que veamos qué pasa
primero estaba en este número que es
igual a este a la potencia 20 llegó acá
a la potencia 21 llegó acá de hecho cada
vez que elevó o multiplicó a este número
por sí mismo estoy agregando 2 pitt
hercios al argumento por lo tanto esto
sería el número a la potencia 1 a la
potencia 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 regreso aquí